these are times that are difficult for
everyone many people are drinking more
than usual wondering what time in the
afternoon can they really start drinking
well guess what we just picked up a
brand new sponsor a sponsor who's
telling us that during these times you
can start drinking a lot earlier than
you'd think and they have a new product
to help get that message across these
are the good people at Dundee Valley
wines and here is their latest product
for these times Dundee valleys breakfast
wine is the only one fermented with real
California style raisins originally
intended for prison oatmeal Dundee
valleys breakfast wine pairs perfectly
with cereal coffee fruit even eggs
spread breakfast wine on your morning
toast or a fortify that cold Pizza you
found on your pillow but don't really
remember ordering and try our extra
thick formula on waffles pancakes or
just straight from the bottle
you'll find Dundee Valley breakfast wine
and breakfast wine concentrate in your
liquor stores frozen food section just
look for the bottle with the alcoholic
grape on it